coral is kind of like the trees of a
forest they're just the backbone of a
whole
tropical ecosystem and if they disappear
we're in a lot of trouble
my name is ken niedemeyer i'm the
founder of the coral restoration
foundation
the reason i'm doing this i was i've
been growing up diving spent a lot of
time in the water one two three
i basically watched the coral reefs
dying as the reefs died the fish didn't
come back and i realized i'm tired of
watching it die i need to do something
about it
and so i developed this whole idea of
growing corals in an offshore nursery
and replanting them on the reef
so you're kind of like a farmer
i'm a farmer
yeah we grow corals just like a farm
there's a good time of the year to plant
and there's a harvest time and we have
five offshore nurseries in the keys
each tree can hold a hundred corals
we start with little fragments that we
collect and after six to nine months
maybe a year that fragment has turned
into a colony that might have 100
centimeters of growth on it we cut that
off and then we plant it out on the reef
so we just harvested some corals and
we're going to take them out to pickles
reef right now and plant them
we've got a couple thousand of them out
there that we've already planted and
we're gonna add some more
it is a bit of gardening when you put
the corals back out on the reef you're
saying i think that would look nice over
there and that would look nice over
there and some of it's based on what
used to be there and what should be
there and that's how we do our planting
we planted 20 000 already this year
we'll plant 25 000 next year those
corals will probably spawn next year
part of the long range goal is get the
corals reproducing on their own
i'm excited every time i get in the
water whether i'm going to work in the
nursery or whether i'm planting corals
or just
looking for new areas to plant a lot of
people said oh you can never do that
it'll never work can't do it on a big
enough scale and i think i've proven
that it can be done and if we can train
enough people and teach enough people in
other places i think we can really see a
significant turnaround another day
another quarrel
[Music]
again
[Music]
is
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alpha
[Music]
grande
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
when you buy from local guys it comes
back to you
and you know you're getting a local fish
it's sustainable that's an honest thing
[Music]
sometimes we forget that we are part of
the ecosystem we are animals too
and we are very ignorant
very ignorantly
so
[Music]
the
[Music]
i kind of compare it with being at a
giant
dog park some of them love it like you
start giving them armpit scratches and
they're just like giant dogs they just
start rolling around and they're flying
all around you but these animals are
huge
people are intimidated by them but once
you once you learn their behavior
they're just right into you right away
they just look at you like a big chew
toy
[Music]
i could never see myself living anywhere
other than the pacific northwest
i could literally spend every single day
the rest of my life and never travel
anywhere other than vancouver island and
i would still never have enough time to
see this whole place
my first introduction to the ocean would
have definitely come from my mom just me
the sea lion right there later on in
life realize it is a pretty unique
experience to get to out and spend time
with these animals on a regular basis
sea lions are a large
intelligent animal and they're very
sensitive of what your intentions are
and and how they choose to interact with
you is totally their choice
if you're comfortable and and they're
inquisitive they'll come and they'll
chew on your fans or they come up and
they chew on the edge of your mask or
give you big kisses on the lips or big
hugs they wrap their fins around you and
give you a big hug
people get sketched out about it
like i've had lots of people contact me
and be like don't you think those things
are aggressive just because in animals
putting its mouth on you doesn't mean
it's doing it in a harmful way they
don't have hands they can't explore
their world with anything other than
their mouth
there's people that spend
a lot of money to travel to the other
side of the planet to watch a group of
large migratory animals in africa or
something say
and here i can just go out on my boat
and it's not something i take for
granted at all anymore having the
opportunity to do this
[Music]
i recently told somebody that getting
attacked by a shark was the greatest
thing that's ever happened to me they're
like that's absurd or that you know why
would you say that
i've had incredible opportunities i've
been able to visit some really cool
places and meet some incredible people
all these things have been nurtured from
the shark attack
i think it's really made me who i am
today
[Music]
my name is mike cootes i live in the
island of kauai in hawaii i'm a surfer
photographer and shark attack survivor
there's some really great surf spots out
here i was 18 years old surfing here on
kauai with some friends and it was early
in the morning and i paddled out and
thought i was gonna have a surf session
like any other day and
it was a lot different i got attacked by
a tiger shark as soon as i hit it it let
go and disappeared back underwater and i
remember passing out basically as soon
as we got to the hospital and i woke up
a day and a half later an amputee
[Music]
i got my first prosthetic six months
after the shark attack
early on you think you can't do this you
think you can't do that you know there's
these physical limitations on life and
i didn't think i could drive a truck
with a stick shift and you learn how to
drive a truck with a stick shift and
you're like wow that was cool and you
build up these little things like day to
day to day after while it's like bring
it on what what can happen that i can't
figure out how to do
i was in college and i remember class
got out i was like you know what i'm
gonna take a longboard i'm gonna get the
biggest board i could find and just take
my prosthetic in the water and see what
happens
i caught a wave and
i was screaming pretty loud i was like
what this is cool this is amazing and i
think that was like the best wave i had
ever caught in my life
from then on i started figuring out okay
what's going to break what can i make
that's a foot that will help me surf
even better and trying to basically make
the ultimate surfing foot
i think i'm doing it because it's fun
but i'm also it's this learning
experience and it's taking this
information and passing it on to people
that want to surf with a prosthetic
the ocean has taken a lot for me but
what it's given back to me has been
immeasurable i've lost you know nearly
my life to a shark yet i really believe
sharks are
one of the if not the most important
species in our marine ecosystem at the
rate that they're being killed off
they're not going to be around in 10 15
20 years and why not use something that
could i guess be said as a negative and
turn into a positive
the shark attack's been the greatest
thing that's ever happened
[Music]
you